hey guys I have another video for you I
want to talk about the difference
between burning calories in general and
burning fat calories isn't the goal to
burn fat calories so many people say
well I'm going to go and exercise I have
to burn up my calories I just ate you
know they're in the calorie burning but
what kind of calories are they burning
typically when you actually go an
exercise it's very rare that you're
going to burn any fat calories at all in
fact go ahead and try this experiment go
ahead and work out three hours weigh
yourself just before the workout and
right after and see how much weight that
you lost it'll be zero because the
calories that you burn when you exercise
are mainly mainly sugar stored sugar
calories in the form of glycogen
glycogen is a bunch of sugar molecules
attached together glucose molecules
attach together as one unit and that's
called glycogen
so you store it in the muscle and you
store it in the liver okay so when you
exercise you basically tap out your
glycogen reserve so you deplete it and
then you think oh wow it burned out my
calories I'm I'm going to lose weight
right well it depends what really
determines if you to burn fat calories
is if you keep your dietary
carbohydrates or glucose really low the
big mistake that I see when people
workout is they'll they'll eat some
fruit after the workout they'll drink a
protein sugar shake they'll drink some
juice after the workout Gatorade with
the glucose and fructose you know as
their electrolyte and it pretty much
nullified any benefit of exercise
because as soon as that sugar goes in
there that exercise you're going to
basically burn up that sugar instead of
your own fat okay if you exercise in the
absence of glucose or sugar diet diet
wise you will trigger hormones that will
then work for you 48 or 24 to 48 hours
later okay when you're sleeping so
that's really the benefit of exercise
it's in the recovery later not during
the workout but if you have any sugar
before during or after
you pretty much are not going to be
burning this type of calorie right here
and I think people give this give the
wrong importance to calories as a whole
if they will eat everything in
moderation eat a less and you'll lose
weight because of course you know
calories in calories out well no that's
not how it works and if you avoid fat
calories they have the most dense dense
calories or more calories per unit than
carbs or protein but the fat calories
are neutral when it comes down to
triggering insulin so when you eating
less calories it really talks about what
are you what less what type of calories
are you eating less of if you're eating
less of carbohydrate calories then
you're good if you're eating less of fat
calories in keeping your carbohydrates
high it's very very bad you're not going
to lose fat so it's not about burning
calories it's about burning fat calories
to do that you have to keep your glucose
and your sugar as low as possible I like
to recommend keep it below between 20
and 50 grams if you really want to lose
weight keep it below 20 okay and that's
what's going to help it's not about
eating less calories it's not about
exercising it's about understanding the
whole picture hormone Lee thanks for
watching hey you probably already
subscribed but if you haven't press this
little button down below and I will keep
you updated